As an entrepreneur,
when you start working with an investor,
there are some compromises that
are going to have to be made.
And one way of thinking about that
is when you make your first pitch to
an investor,
the investor starts formulating in their
mind what they think this company should
become, what the product should be.
And that may not be
the same idea that you have
in your head as the entrepreneur.
And actually,
part of picking the right investors is,
is there alignment
between these visions,
the vision that the investor shares and
the vision that the entrepreneur shares?
And no matter how close
those two visions are,
sometimes there's going to
be some differences.
And as an entrepreneur,
what you have to decide is
when the investor's vision is slightly
different, are you going to adjust?
Are you going to course correct?
And when you're thinking
about doing that and
you're thinking about those compromises,
it's important to take a step back and
think about it from
the investor's perspective.
They're not in the weeds.
They're not in the detail.
Maybe they're looking
at the bigger picture.
Maybe they're looking at other
companies in the marketplace.
And you have to constantly evaluate,
should you course correct or
should you really remain on your vision?
Ultimately though,
if you're taking money from investors,
there are going to be
compromises you have to make.
They're going to ask you to do
things that may not have been your
first priority and, sometimes you're
just going to have to do that.
And it comes down to making sure
that your investors are really good
and that their ideas are sound.
And if they are,
sometimes they're going to tell you
something that you didn't think of and
you're going to have to correct.